L'astronaute David Saint-Jacques
est avec nous.
- Bonjour.
- Qu'est-ce qui est arrivé?
Expliquez-nous simplement, il y
avait une fuite?
Qu'est-ce énervé?
- C'est un vol d'essai, c'est la
première fois que ce système
complet été essayé et toute
assemblée.
C'est un peu comme une
répétition générale avant les
premières missions habitées.
Tout le monde voulait que ça
marche, mais on savait qu'il y
avait des grandes chances qu'on
trouve un problème.
C'est presque rassurant, ça veut
dire que ces ingénieurs portent
attention.
Il y a eu un problème qui n'ont
pas été résolu.
Il y avait des foudres, à
retardement du carburant, il y a
eu une fuite, mais finalement ce
fut résolu.
Problème de communication.
Dans les minutes qui ont précédé
le lancement, il y avait des
pertes de moteurs principaux qui
n'arrivaient pas à température
désirée, ce n'était pas clair
pourquoi, si c'est un
thermomètre qui ne fonctionne
pas.
On a décidé qu'on ne prenait pas
la chance.
Dans ses missions, ce que
l'histoire nous a appris, c'est
que c'est tellement compliqué et
dangereux tout cela, il faut
vraiment décoller seulement
qu'on est certain et ce n'est
pas aujourd'hui malheureusement.
Vendredi c'est la prochaine
fenêtre qui s'ouvre.
Vendredi on verra.
On pourra peut-être assurer que
cette fois ça va marcher.
- Oui, mais comme vous dîtes
c'est rassurant aussi, ça veut
dire qu'on apprend aucune
chance.
Pourquoi la fenêtre est si
petite comme ça?
Parce que la lune bouge, mais on
peut changer la trajectoire,
non?
- Aujourd'hui c'était deux
heures qu'on avait.
Deux heures de marche qu'on
avait pour ajuster le tir.
On n'a pas une quantité infinie
de carburant et on a d'autres
contraintes comme il ne faut pas
que le vaisseau spatial passe
dans l'ombre de la terre.
On peut penser à dans deux
semaines quand on revient si on
a des bonnes conditions pour
revenir, c'est un calendrier
compliqué.
Le prochain bloc vendredi
prochain.
- Pourquoi on retourne,
justement va retourner autour de
la Lune.
Artémis deux sera habitée par
des astronautes et on va aussi
faire des rotations autour de la
Lune.
Pourquoi on fait ça?
- Artémis deux avec un équipage,
et aussi un astronaute canadien
ou canadienne.
- Ça c'est ma dernière question,
est-ce que ça sera vous?
- J'aimerais ça.
On est quatre astronautes actifs
au sein de l'agence spatiale
canadienne et s'est fait dans
une grosse collaboration
internationale pour le meilleur
équipage possible.
Tout le monde veut être
impliqué.
La plupart des gens ont
travaillé sur Artémis.
- C'est votre campagne
électorale.
- C'est pas le résultat d'un
vote ou d'un concours de
popularité.
- Mais vous souhaitez d'abord.
- Oui évidemment.
Quand je regardais la terre et
des fois je regardais la lune et
je me disais : on pourrait peut-
être aller faire un tour.
- On va se reparler, il reste 30
secondes, mais expliquez-moi
pourquoi on retourne sur la
lune?
On est retourné il y a 50 avec
Apollo?
- Oui c'est la génération
Apollo, ça peut impressionner
les carrières.
Maintenant cela génération
Artémis, on retombe sur la lune
pour y rester.
On fera une station en orbite
autour de la lune et c'est pour
apprendre et se rassurer qu'on
peut vivre dans l'espace de
manière plus prolongée pour oser
aller ve